[Musik]
ein ungewöhnliches terrain für einen
marketing profi in der markthalle in
langnau im emmental geht alois wies
schon mal auf tuchfühlung mit seiner
kind das verkaufstalent erkennt man
sofort sobald alois im ring steht
[Musik]
das verkaufen liegt alois wies im blut
im ring ist der 71-jährige in hochform
[Musik]
der vollblut rhetoriker ist in seinem
element
ein spruch voll mit dem anna alois ist
einer von nur noch vier professionellen
ganz rufern in der deutschschweiz den
verkauf in der zentral und westschweiz
und im bernbiet hat die luzerner geprägt
wie kein anderer
am wichtigsten ist ihm dabei der mensch
sagt er auch die verantwortlichen hier
schätzen die jahrzehntelange
verkaufserfahrung von alois dass das ist
rom
[Musik]
alois stammt selber aus einer
bauernfamilie hier in grosswangen im
luzernischen hinterland ist er
aufgewachsen den hof betreibt seine
familie mit einem angestellten
[Musik]
einmal pro woche ist geräte tag dann
werden motoren kontrolliert große und
kleine hat eine förderung rechnen gleich
drei aber eben zu der von ihr geld nicht
und das ist schon oft aber das hobby zu
der über logo das den zusatz soll
und da wir sind glücklich wenn ich
hunger und minirock nicht zu ertragen
sein wort geben nicht auf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dies führt eine alte familientradition
weiter bereits sei nur und sein
großvater war ganghofer sein vater hat
ihn mit 19 jahren sozusagen in die
branche rein geschubst an einer großen
ganzen behauptete schubert lohnt so
honda fahrer da bin ich auch die treffen
und das hat natürlich immer von pato
schoss sie mit mikrofon nachschauen das
publikum und die polizei und jalil
hingelegt und braucht über windige
letztlich auch die frist für alois wurde
als naturtalent bezeichnet schnell war
er sehr bekannt schaffte es sogar in ein
porträt buch und viele andere
publikationen
seine ehefrau anna ließ hat ihn auf
einer land kennengelernt
hallo es ist durch seinen beruf immer im
mittelpunkt gestanden und genießt das
auch heute noch
er ist auch bei frauen immer gut
angekommen
[Musik]
tja und da bin ich da noch was rosa
locker und xl geschossen und den platz
doch ja ich das so wie damals wanderten
viele bauern ins ausland ab aloys hat
viele höfe und ganze existenzen im ring
verkauft und war ein richtiger star
seine frau sieht das ein bisschen anders
sie kennt ihn hat nicht nur als
verkaufsprofi
spezieller moment
pflegeleicht weil sie darin lächerlich
frau für meine frau und ich beweglichen
spitzen hinter dem berg gehalten
im haushalt und auf dem hof schaut also
an alice zum rechten vor allem wenn ihr
mann unterwegs ist denn seine welt ist
die gans
[Musik]
vor 20 jahren noch war er manchmal von
januar bis april fast täglich als ganz
rufer unterwegs
heute fährt er immer noch rund 50.000
kilometer pro jahr
die schicksale seiner kunden
beschäftigten ihn immer auch persönlich
[Musik]
die frau hatte mehrere dieser frau
radtour telefoniert werden
schluchzend am telefon 069 mit dem usa
und natürlich so belastete die zeiten
der bauern auswanderungen aus
wirtschaftlichen gründen sind vorbei
wenn heute ein bauer seinen hof auf gibt
fehlt ihm in der regel ein nachfolger
anders bei allianz er ist schwer krank
und will nun sein vieh verkaufen
seine kühe sind zwar begehrte und
preisgekrönte zuchttiere doch keiner
seiner zwei söhne will und kann die kühe
übernehmen einen bauernhof als hobby zu
führen
funktioniert in unserer zeit nicht mehr
tun um den geliebten crew der anrufe
will genaue angaben zu den kühen von
allianz durch seine jahrzehntelange
erfahrung als verkaufsprofi weiß er
genau was wichtig ist bei einer
steigerung auch ein inserat im vorfeld
gehört dazu mit einer kuh aber auch die
genauen milch leistungszahlen zu den
kursen bekannt sein dass er seine kühe
verkaufen muss beschäftigt den berner
oberländer
daraus zieht ist aber hörte fragen geht
das auch eine immer wo ich ja hier blieb
auf dem hof gewesen aber in der
stadtmühle aber olic ins zelt auch auf
die guten verkaufskosten von alois
dieser ist dank seiner bekanntheit auch
ein garant für viele gute kunden das
cuxhavener auf dem selbst gemachten
kuchen hat genützt
[Musik]
die zucht kühe ließen sich an der
privaten ganz dann tatsächlich zu einem
sehr guten preis verkaufen
auch nach abschluss des geschäfts bleibt
wie es in kontakt mit einem kranken
kunden
ein verkaufstalent kann alles verkaufen
manchmal geht er dafür weite wege und
lässt sich dabei auch überraschen
ja was die frau für kunstwerke wie für
stück von der betrag für eine steigerung
versteigerung rentiert das drin liegt
dass ich die priorität ich habe noch nie
erlebt
die frau könne wie eine große künstlerin
das taxi abholen der fahne hoch
auch hier sind seine verkaufs künste und
das große netzwerk aus 50 jahren gefragt
die künstlerin möchte dass er ihre
bilder verkauft schnell ist man und was
sie eigentlich die details enthalten wo
man erst bemerkt man es auch betrachtet
also die bilder sind noch speziell dass
sie endet
im keller bei der bilderpräsentation
wird dann klar was die künstlerin genau
von ihm möchte ich dir und schafft die
potenzielle kundschaft die szene aber es
ist ein spezielles mannschaft und das
wissen nicht immer aber meistens gut
wenn wir die negativen gedanken am ende
weg nun anders der nettoerlöse im moment
sind sie sich also noch nicht einig
geworden
große hoffnung kann sich die künstlerin
offensichtlich nicht machen sie
wunderschön ist auch großartige sache
aber wie immer wir wie man das team
vermarkten das ist entscheidend wie man
darf herr bringen
das ist jetzt andere situation und wir
schaffen das ist sich kundig machen aber
knallhart das oder manch einer sagen
wenn wir die babys entscheide für das
gilt für die rentengarantie
hundertprozentige garantie für erfolg
aber im event merklich erhöhte garantie
die geschäfte außerhalb der
landwirtschaft sind wichtig denn nur von
den kanten kann wie es nicht leben
dabei bekommt er je nach auftraggeber
eine pauschale oder bis zwei prozent des
umsatzes sagt er
er macht sein geld auch mit
liegenschaften kunst oder maschinen dies
alles mit einem klaren prinzip neben
nemanja potenziellen dass ich mir enorm
da ist also grundsätze übernommen womit
gewaltig diesbezüglich
[Musik]
bin und angespanntem es gab aber dankbar
das ist seine liebste welt in der
markthalle tun
fühlt er sich wohl
[Musik]
hier gibt er das tempo vor
ausgebildet 58 und die patriotische
berner oberländer höhe und die bremer
nicht mehr richtig charisma kollege das
leben ist ein nehmen und geben der
geschichte des coaches er ist 71 jahre
alt und manche sagen man glaubt es ihm
kaum erträglich und friedrich von der
flotte brite gleich und gebote
friedlicher junge 5650 aber wie merck
der gant rufe überhaupt verkaufen will
natürlich die leute so anonym und
diskret bleiben die meisten oder gesorgt
das ist das geheimnis um ihr könnt
natürlich die nyt nach aldi oder etwa
100 und dafür an dem auch das papier
heute ist ein besonderer gast bei der
steigerung dabei es ist der 83 jährige
heinrich villiger der zigarren patron
[Musik]
dessen unternehmen ist seit über drei
jahrzehnten sponsor der kanten im ganzen
land die beiden haben nicht nur die
zusammenarbeit und die reife gemeinsam
auch die zukunft frage ist bei beiden
offen kristallisiert oder aber im moment
kann da vinci oder studieren
was machen sie mit den nachfahren haben
20 jährige tochter dresen und tochter
die draisinen andré brie
die 20-jährige tochter ich hoffe
natürlich dass die kur mit meinem job
aber natürlich natürlich zu interesse
und das ist spezielle beruf zurück zu
hause in grosswangen
[Musik]
sein sohn christoph aus erster ehe ist
metro kabine und nur alle zwei monate
bei seinem vater zu besuch
obwohl der gant rufer vier kinder hat
will keiner in seine fußstapfen treten
auch christoph hat sich ging an land
leben entschieden
eine familientradition die schon vor 20
jahren am schweizer fernsehen
porträtiert worden ist findet nun
wahrscheinlich ihr ende
[Musik]
über seine nachfolge regelt der gant
hofer gar nicht gerne
der prozess musste und die mährische
vorstellen wenn natürlich riecht oft
plötzlich doch oder er geht mit der
zukunft frage auf seine ganz eigene art
um
[Musik]
doch grundsätzlich stellt sich schon die
frage wie lange sein beruf anrufer
überhaupt noch existieren wird wurde die
ingenieure für die option einen
logischen anderer kracht und lebt auch
nur control vergeben konkrete das gleich
wieder hingestellt
es wird sich steigern reaktionen
dezember siegerin andrea wir denn
effektive sehr elegant rufen monitor
sitzt über die songs kapitel
richtig oder ganz rufe alois mit 50
jähriger verkaufserfahrung nach
traditioneller art wäre einer der
letzten seines standes
[Musik]